thank you so much peaceful protests
across the country were upended by
violence over the weekend
clashes erupted in multiple cities the
protests focused around police brutality
were seemingly inflamed by president
trump's plans to deploy
more federal agents many demonstrators
say the violence undermines their
message
in austin texas one man was killed
during a march there
carter evans has been following the
unrest
[Music]
footage uploaded to facebook captures
the moments shots rang out in downtown
austin
about 100 people were marching at the
time
one of them 28 year old garrett foster
was killed
police say foster who had protested
regularly since the death of george
floyd was
legally carrying an ak-47 at the time
he and other protesters according to
authorities surrounded a car
after the driver turned aggressively
toward demonstrators
the driver opened fire striking foster
before speeding away
the driver later called 9-1-1 and claims
foster pointed a rifle at them
before they fired in return his wife be
an african-american and he'd be in a
camping of justice and wanting to to
make sure that all people are treated
fairly and equally
in aurora colorado a blue jeep barreled
through a sea of protesters who quickly
parted to avoid being hit
police say one person opened fire
wounding at least one other demonstrator
police declared a riot in seattle
saturday night after vandals set fires
and destroyed property
authorities deployed tear gas and pepper
spray
daryl bro's car was seriously damaged in
the melee and she says
those using the demonstrations as cover
for mayhem
drowning out the positive meaning of the
protests almost 45 years
i've been black this is what black lives
matter does
i'm not with it those protests are
drawing inspiration from portland where
people have been gathering for nearly 60
days and nights
tear gas was fired again sunday with
some using signs and leaf blowers to
push the gas
back on officers peaceful protesters
like these two nurses
were caught in the crossfire that was my
first time being tear gas and
it is not fun there's nothing violent
about our protest
and police here in los angeles say what
started as a peaceful protest over the
weekend got out of hand when a small
group of protesters
started assaulting police officers the
federal building was vandalized
well now president trump is doubling
down still planning to send
federal troops to cities like chicago
detroit
and philadelphia anthony carter evans